the jurgen experience let's break down
how that works okay so first of all what
are the numbers what's the number of
homeless people in los angeles currently
because los angeles is the big problem
if you'll be the governor you're gonna
have to deal with obviously san
francisco is the other big problem san
diego much less so right i'll tell you
the official numbers but they're wrong
because they're two and a half years old
and they were probably under counts into
in the year 2020 but it's in la county
60 000 homeless
in la city 44 000.
all of california a hundred and sixteen
thousand unsheltered meaning outside
intense
a hundred and sixty thousand total
meaning
unsheltered and in shelters how is it a
hundred thousand in los angeles in los
angeles county and los angeles city but
in only another 16 000 in the rest of
the state no no 60 000 in la county
right but you said 40 000 in la prop oh
yeah sorry but that's um the 60 000
includes the 44 000. okay and san
francisco has somewhere between i would
say
officially it has 8 000 total homeless
but i but i think it's much more likely
to be 10 to 12 000 total homeless of
whom
six to
i would say around six to eight are
unsheltered
now and during a year at least 20 25 000
unsheltered homeless pass through the
city so you get a lot of so do you
consider that people without tents are
they unsheltered no no they're the
people in the tents are considered
unsheltered homeless oh okay so these
are the sheltered the only people
considered sheltered are people in
official shelters
yeah so roughly speaking you're talking
about somewhere in the neighborhood of
200 000 people in the state it could be
that many
it's a daunting task when you consider
it
particularly since the models that we
have are of the five european cities
that shut down
their homeless encampments my one thing
i discovered is that the europeans
called them open drug scenes we
euphemistically refer to them as
homeless encampments which makes them
sound like they're roasting they're
making marshmallow s'mores yeah and it
also brings us back to that they're down
on their luck right narratives right
that they're okies is the picture
they're just okies they just can't
afford the rent no they're not there
okies well remember the remember uh
grapes of wrath uh the john steinbeck
novel is the oh they came from the dust
bowl in oklahoma they came to california
and then they lived in tents and so this
archetypal when you know people that
would never go and talk to homeless
people or much less interview them they
look at those tents and they go they're
poor people that's like how the
mentality works as opposed to like no no
they became addicted to hard drugs they
stopped working they overstayed their
welcome with friends and family
they were they usually often
often stole
money or lied or cheated from the folks
they're staying with and then they were
finally kicked out onto the street and
then they go just live
in the open drug markets and the open
drug markets become the open drug scenes
one of the characters in san francisco
he was like when we were walking through
the tenderloin which is like the skid
row of san francisco he goes yeah that's
the door well i used to sleep in because
i didn't want to walk the i didn't want
to walk five blocks away to the shelter
i wanted to be right where the drug
dealers were
so part of it is that you see the other
thing is that like
the people often in the open drug scene
might not be homeless in the sense that
they might actually have places to stay
but what you'll see when you watch the
open drug scenes is that people will
come on their bikes so they'll walk
they'll buy the drugs from the dealers
and they'll use them right there
they're in such a hurry to get their fix
they'll buy the fentanyl and meth and
they'll just sit right there and then
after over a period of time
they're just there yeah all the time
with their little foil and lightening
the methane fentanyl and smoking it and
they just become
catatonic so so we have these numbers
let's just whatever the number is in l.a
a hundred thousand let's say a hundred
thousand um let's start with la
what is available in terms of shelter
and do you make new buildings do you buy
buildings yes
both yep and it's not clear that i don't
i'm not sure yet i have my we have a
working group on this
and so we're looking at this it's not
clear where you start
one argument is that you start where you
have the strongest local political
support so there is a mayoral election
in la
we'll see what happens but for example
let's say the sacramento mayor
is like michael we love your whole
agenda let's start in sacramento
so we because i'm what i know what i
feel very strongly about is that success
breeds success so we want to start
somewhere where we get some good
outcomes
where we see a big difference in a
pretty short period of time by which i
mean months not years
that it's humane
that we are using our emergency powers
the the least amount necessary because
we want to protect human rights and
individual rights which are now being
violated
we want to protect those rights we want
to limit the powers that the governor
has because the governor has absolutely
extraordinary powers in disaster
situations which is what this is you get
success now you get people into shelter
you get people into rehabs you get some
people into psych hospitals you might
actually get people to go back home to
kentucky or colorado or wherever they
came from
but i think it's also fair to assume
that some amount of those so-called home
unsheltered homeless addicts
and mentally ill people will go
somewhere else in the state where
they're not being required to stay in
the shelters because of course you've
got to enforce the no camping you got to
enforce the camping ban
otherwise people otherwise you destroy
your cities which are being destroyed
now and people are not getting the help
they need so one vision is that you
would start where you have the strongest
local support another vision is that you
start in a smaller town
another vision is that you start where
it's hardest which is which is la i
would say start in la just because it's
too far gone and it needs to be cleaned
up as quickly as possible and some
headway needs to be done because it's
just gonna keep growing have you paid
attention to what happened in austin
yes austin's been pretty interesting
yeah because the this the mayor who i
had on the podcast
he
really clearly stated that this is his
goal he said i want to clean this up
before i leave office and if i don't do
that i'll consider my tenure of failure
good and he did a lot he's reversed
himself because there was about he had a
ballot initiative passed that banned
camping
he he was the one that that allowed
public campaign right and then there was
a balance of the past that banned it
now my understanding is that a lot of
unsheltered homeless have moved into the
woods
have moved into other parts of austin
i i haven't tracked it closely but i
mean at the end they've done a lot to
put people into shelters that's great
but the thing is if you don't kidnap
them it's very difficult i mean i'm not
saying you should kidnap people but i'm
saying if you don't physically force
them into doing something these people
i mean by nature that like this the type
of person that's willing to live on a
tent on caesar chavez like that is a
that's a radical mindset sorry to use
the word radical again but
they've disintegrated yeah i mean you've
gone there they've lost their yeah
they've exactly
a lawn chair on a major street right in
front of this tent that you live in and
you're drinking water out of an old milk
jug that you bought or got somewhere
it's crazy
the whole thing is crazy and they've
done a great job
in austin of cleaning it up but one of
the things that the mayor said what i
talked to him about he said
we can
clean up 3000 people we can do that he
goes but if it gets to where los angeles
is that's untenable it's unmanageable
that's what his thought was yeah he felt
like it was so far gone that no one had
the resources to gather up all those
people and get them off the streets and
like that's not true well okay like skid
row yeah that would be where you would
start you want to start start at skid
row i don't know that we'll start there
that's what i'm saying see what i'm
saying like that's such a good get there
well yeah i mean the other issue is that
and let me just address this other issue
which you you raised i think it's an
important issue which is like
if we let's say we do a really good job
and we get addicts and mentally ill
people coming more of them coming to
california and then we're
shouldering the burden for the entire
country
there's two answers to that first is
that we're going to need to ask the
states that sent us their people to take
to share that burden
and or we're going to need to go to
congress and be like look if we're going
to treat the nation's addicts in rehab
facilities then we're going to need to
be reimbursed we have mechanisms to do
that there's also a real danger if this
becomes a place where people can go to
clean up and people can go to be taken
care of that more people that's right
and then crime increases and then more
people leave the state right which i
mean
the numbers of people that have left
california over the last couple years
are staggering that's right
we need all the other issues yes that's
definitely a concern so you also need
more police officers so i point out you
don't have to choose between mass
homelessness and mass incarceration
but that means that you need the three
key p's more police
more psychiatry and more probation
so that is for sure part of this agenda
i think the other part of it that's not
appreciated is that you need more
development when you visit skid row so
i'm i'm i'm not a i spend i've been in
cal i've been in northern california
since 1993. when i went to skid row i
was like this neighborhood is awesome i
mean if you ignore the complete human
depravity and tragedy on the ground real
estate yeah you look around the
buildings and like it's sunny and it's
near the highways and you're like this
is an incredible neighborhood it needs
to be redeveloped it needs to have you
need to have a much broader mix of
people in there they tried to do that
for a while right and it's to some
extent it's happening but it needs to
happen much more significantly which
means that we need to
expedite and cut the red tape and get
those buildings redeveloped and get
people in there and then it means that a
lot of those services
you don't have like there's no
there's no constitutional right to just
go to be in skid row or in downtown l.a
or downtown san francisco and just be
given a free apartment if you want rehab
or if you're arrested and given the
choice of rehab or prison
the rehab you might get might be in
fresno or bakersfield or it might be in
yuba county or it might be in the
sierras and that might be where you
should that might be the best place to
be 90-day
rehab facility or 120 days where you're
then on a fire crew i mean for heaven's
sake we need many more people working on
preparing for us for and to prevent
fires for example as one of the many
things that we need to do like cleanups
cleaning absolutely prescribed burns
that's like manual hard labor
not everybody's gonna do it some people
might learn python at at rehab some
people might learn woodwork python
that's just a basic programming language
oh
you're talking about like cleaning up
pythons before you ship them out to
florida
maybe that too uh
this can be i mean one of the
revolutions that we have not taken
advantage either in schooling or in in
mental health care or rehab is
personalization i mean everybody's
different like there's some people that
should be doing
people that we'd great on a fire crew
you know working on cal fire other
people you know could be helping other
people to get into recovery so we can do
all those things with a centralized
system with a really good centralized
system and the other key ingredient that
we don't have is
professional assertive case managers
where somebody is tracking your progress
if you're arrested or you overdose and
you go into rehab
before you get out there's a plan for
you so that you don't just go right back
on the street and start smoking fentanyl
and overdose and die or just become an
addict again there's some plan for you
and we're going to keep a close eye on
you and make sure that you commit to
that plan
we know that people relapse but we can
reduce that amount of relapsing with a
really engaged good assertive case
manager and it may be that this is
someone
who does have a potential to be reunited
with his family in ohio if that's the
path that's great and we'll work with
i'll work with the governor of ohio to
get that done i'll work with the the
congress to make sure that there's
medicaid money for that person to get
fixed
and repair their life but right now
there is nothing like that and that's
what cal psych would do so in the
emergency response i give myself two
years before we go back to voters
i'm going to put as soon as we come into
office day one go to the legislature and
be like here's my legislation for
shelter first
that's the first thing shelter first
treatment first housing earned you don't
have an entitlement to your own
apartment in l.a you don't just get to
go to la and be like hey i'm a homeless
or i got to give me my own apartment
doesn't work
it's not ethical it's not fair okay but
if they do go there and then they don't
work
well they're just gonna be homeless if
you can't so we are we're gonna enforce
a statewide camping ban so where do you
start venice like that's a good eyesore
i mean give me give me i've got a little
bit of time to figure out where we start
and some of it will depend on politics
have you run numbers with anybody we're
doing that right now yeah so yeah it
seems like it's gonna we're gonna come
in
on my inauguration day with legislation
that goes in from the legislature
and i'm going to take emergency actions
as governor to deal with the disaster we
can get fema shelter set up triage tents
we can get the national guard involved
if we need to in a strictly civilian
capacity how many people do you need in
terms of like counselors police officers
law enforcement just to handle the
homeless problem it seems like you need
a a team oh
it's a huge that's that's a great
question that's in many ways
there's sort of the institutional
arrangement there's where do you start
geographically
there's how do you do the legal side i
assume we'll just be sued by aclu that's
fine we'll go to court over what we're
doing that's fine and then there's
workforce and in some ways the workforce
is the most important thing we're losing
i mean both la and san francisco are
short like 500 police officers at this
point